I accept that the prosecutor that the
defense solicitors commissioned expert
reports to ensure there was no
psychiatric defense to the charge of
murder and to ensure Fitness to plead
and to be tried these were responsible
steps in a case of such gravity
I also accept that because of the action
taken by criminal barristers the
defendant was not able to receive advice
from Junior barristers or King's Council
until October this year
I reject the suggestion from the defense
that because he was heard on a prison
phone telling his mother that he was
banged to rights he should be taken to
have indicated at a very very early
stage that he would accept
responsibility for the killing he never
indicated this to the court until the
16th of November and at stages his
non-engagement frustrated the work being
done on his behalf
in addition as Mr Carter Stevenson
accepted in his written submission on
sentence
he caused some additional delay through
taking a belligerent attitude when
required to come to court including
telling the jailers on one occasion that
there was no point in attending a
hearing at which he was required
overall my conclusion is
that the defendant is entitled to less
than the maximum discount on the murder
count and I would allow one-eighth
although given the length of the term I
will impose the maximum discount allowed
can be five years
considering all these features
after a trial the minimum term would
have been 43 years
I allow five years as I have said for
the plea of guilty indicated by Council
on the 16th of November a few weeks
before trial
a sentence of four years concurrent is
imposed for sexual assault
the sentence for the brutal sexually
motivated murder of Zara Alina is
imprisonment for Life the defendant will
serve 38 years as the minimum term
the court would like to thank Council
and also to commend Mr and Mrs Condor
Georgina Woolard and Maria Bergen